في تطورات جديده في قصه الفنانه شيرين عبد
الوهاب اللي شغلت الناس وتصدرت وما زالت
متصدره العناوين وكان في كثير اشاعات طلعت
على الفنانه ان كان وفاتها او سفرها
الخارج للعلاج او حتى هروبها من المستشفى
يعني سلسله من الاخبار والاشاعات اللي
نفاها محامي شيرين على صفحته الشخصيه في
الايام الماضيه لكن في تزور جديد اليوم
نسف كل شيء اخبار من قبل كانت صغيره فمن
بعد 17 يوم على دخول المستشفى خرج شيرين
اخيرا منها ونشر محامينها المستشار ياسر
ان تش على صفحه انه هي بصحه جيده وشكر كل
من دعمها وقال انه في فيديو قريبا هيشرح
في المستجددات
ولكن قبل ما تخرج شيرين من المستشفى كانت
تشير لها تسجيل صوتي وتم تداوله على
المنصات وهي بتطلب مساعده محاميها
مساء الخير يا استاذ ياسر ههه من فضلك
بتعمل اي حاجه عشان تخرجني من المستشفى
لان هم ادوني على ورقه انا مش عارفه ورق
ايه ده وانا عايزه اخرج من المستشفى انا
الحمد لله بقيت كويسه وكملت علاج يعني بقى
لي 20 يوم هنا فعايزه اخرج ضروري يا استاذ
ياسر من فضلك
طب يعني مثل ما سمعته في التسجيل الفنان
شيرين
هذه طلعت من بعد ما تداوي اخبار انه شيرين
طلبت من المستشفى البقاء للعلاج والمستشفى
كانت ابلغت النيابه العامه بقرار شيرين
لكن اللي تبين بعدين صادم وعكس ذلك تماما
فنشر محامي شيرين همم بيان قال في انه في
تقرير صادر عن المجلس القومي للصحه
النفسيه اكد انه شيرين صحتها جيده ومستقره
وليست بحاجه للعلاج الالزام داخل المستشفى
وقال لي ان المستشفى ارغم شيرين على
التوقيع على اوراق انه هي تبغى تفضل فيها
للعلاج واكد انه هو راح يتاخذ الاجراء هذا
القانونيه اللازمه بحقهم لانهم الان
بيعتبروا محتاجين شيرين وبدون وجه حق وهذا
الشيء مخالف للقانون ويبدا انه الاجراءات
المطولات وخرجت شيرين اليوم من المستشفى
[موسيقى]